اعتمد مجلس الامن الدولي القرار
2720 بشان توسيع المساعدات الانسانيه الى
قطاع غزه ومراقبتها وقبيل اعتماد القرار
اوقف الفيتو الامريكي اجراء تعديل طلبته
روسيا على مشروع القرار وقد قال المندوب
الروسي في مجلس الامن فاسيلي نير نيزا قال
ان نص مشروع القرار المتعلق بغزه افرغ من
جوهره بسبب ضغوط الولايات المتحده بينما
اكدت المندوبه الامريكيه في المجلس ليندا
توماس جرينفيلد ان القرار يعطي امكانيه
وصول المساعدات لغزه بدون عوائق و ويعد
بارقه امل في ظل هذا المد العارم من
المعاناه وفق
قولها انضم الينا من مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك مراسل الجزيره
مراد هاشم مراد اذا اخيرا اعتمد هذا
القرار ولكن ماذا عن اليه
التنفيذ في ظل وجود اعمال عدائيه كما تريد
الولايات
المتحده بالفعل جمال هذا هو السؤال الاهم
والتحدي الاهم الذي سيقف امام هذا القرار
وامام ترجمته و عا على الارض سيتوقف
الامر بالتاكيد على دور الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وطالما طالما هي سمحت
بمرور وتمرير هذا القرار لم تدعم بالتصويت
بنعم لكنها امتنعت عن التصويت ما سمح
بتمريره بطبيعه
الحال بعد ان اضعفت الصيغه بشكل كبير لكن
الصيغه التي النهائيه التي اعتمدت
ما تزال تدعو الى هدن انسانيه مؤقته
وممرات انسانيه لايصال المساعدات بشكل امن
وسريع وعاجل
والهد لعده ايام وهذا استنادا الى ماده في
القرار السابق 27/12 الصادر عن مجلس الامن
في منتصف الشهر الماضي والذي جاء في ماده
يؤكد عليها يعيد التاكيد عليها هذا القرار
اليوم الصادر اليوم
27 20
لكنه ايضا هذا القرار الجديد يضيف ايضا
الدعوه الى اتخاذ خطوات عاجله وفوريه
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق
وبشكل موسع كذلك تهيئه الظروف من اجل وقف
مستدام
للاعمال القتاليه ما يدفع خطوه ولو محدوده
فيما يتعلق بالاستجابه للمطالب الدوليه
الواسعه لوقف اطلاق النار في غزه هذا
القرار
صيني ماذا يستفيد من هذا القرار اذا كانت
اسرائيل عاده لا تلتزم بقرارات مجلس الامن
والامم
المتحده وهناك في
الواقع العشرات من القرارات التي اعتمدها
مجلس الامن الدولي بشان القضيه الفلسطينيه
ولعقود وترفض اسرائيل تنفيذها وتتجنب
الولايات المتحده من ممارسه ضغوط عليها من
اجل تنفيذها ولكن اهميه هذا القرار انه
يضع ضغط اكثر على اسرائيل الان هناك
ا من
الواضح ان هناك حاله من العزله بالنسبه
لاسرائيل
واعمالها العدائيه وهذه الجرائم كما توصف
في الواقع من قبل الكثير من المنظمات
الحقوقيه الجرائم ضد الانسانيه جرائم
الحرب بل و الاباده الجماعيه كما يذهب بعض
المسؤولين الامميين المعنيين بهذا الشان
هناك ضغط وهذا القرار سيعزز هذه الضغوط
وبطبيعه الحال س هوو ايضا سيشكل الزاما
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا من اجل
ممارسه نفوذها من اجل تنفيذ هذا القرار ال
بطبيعه الحال المكسب الاكبر من هذا القرار
اضافه الى التاكيد على مضامين القانون
الدولي والقانون الدولي لحقوق الانسان
فيما يتعلق بحمايه المدنيين والمنشات
المدنيه والاعيان المدنيه
ا والمسؤوليه بشان ذلك في ولا سيما في
خلال سير الاعمال القتاليه ايضا المساعدات
الانسانيه رغم انه اضعفت الاليه كما كان
يفترض كما جاءت في النص
الاصلي لكن مع ذلك من المفترض في حال ان
نفذ هذا القرار فان مساله تدفق المساعدات
الانسانيه ينبغي ان تتضاعف وان تكون طرق
ايصالها تحت اشراف الامم المتحده ايضا
اكثر واوسع اضافه الى دور اكبر للامم
المتحده فيما يتعلق بهذا الجانب رغم ان
اسرائيل اعفيت من مساله ان تكون الامم
المتحده هي صاحبه السلطه في هذه المساله
وابقي لاسرائيل
بطبيعه الحال اليد العليا ولكن دور الامم
المتحده صار اكبر الان في مساله ايصال
وادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
وبالكميات التي يحتاجها السكان والى وجميع
مناطق القطاع القطاع وسيكون هناك منسق
للشؤون الانسانيه واعاده الاعمار سيكون
معنيا ومكلفا بمتابعه هذه المهمه وستوفر
له الطواقم العمل وكذلك الادوات و كذلك
ايضا الصلاحيه والولايه من اجل ان ينفذ
ذلك هناك ماده تشير بصراحه الى مساله
ضروره ان يصل الوقود بالمستويات الكافيه
الى قطاع غزه وضروره ان تلتزم الاطراف
بالقانون الدولي فيما يتعلق بحمايه
المدنيين ويرفض مساله التشريد القصري
للفلسطينيين هناك جوانب سياسيه مهمه في
هذا القرار حينما يشير الى الى ان غزه جزء
لا يتجزا
من الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وان كذلك
جزء من الدوله الفلسطينيه في اطار حل
الدولتين جمال مراد هاشم مراسل الجزيره في
نيويورك شكرا جزيرا بكا